you can't make your happiness contingent
on getting a libertarian Society the
struggle for liberty will never end
because there's always going to be
status there's always going to be people
who prefer security over Liberty because
that's another part of natural instincts
that people have and so the best that we
can ever accomplish is keeping Liberty
alive and you can keep Liberty alive
just by being a libertarian yourself
hi this is damon root for reason TV and
i'm here today with Randy Barnett law
professor at Georgetown Legal Center and
also one of the attorneys and legal
architects behind the constitutional
challenge to the Patient Protection and
Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare Randy thanks very much for
joining us great great to be here Damon
so obviously we have the decision in the
health care case you're one of the
attorneys for National Federation of
Independent Business arguing against the
constitutionality of obamacare the laws
upheld Chief Justice Roberts upholds the
law now you wrote in The Washington Post
just a few days after the decision came
down we lost on health care but the
Constitution one would you what did you
mean by that right well we lost in our
effort to end Obamacare which is really
what we were trying to do we brought the
action against the mandate for two
reasons one is as a leverage point our
only constitutional leverage point to
defeat Obamacare generally and the
second is because the theory by which
the mandate was enacted if it had been
affirmed by the courts would be a very
dangerous theory in fact it would end
the idea of limited and enumerated
powers of article 1 of the Constitution
said we're really fighting for both
against Obamacare and for the
Constitution and what I was pointing out
in that Washington Post pieces that we
lost in our fight against Obamacare
although in a moment I'm explain why we
may not have lost as badly as some
people think but we ruint one in our
challenge in our effort to preserve the
Constitution and in fact we move the
ball in a positive direction the the
wall street journal editorial page i
think you know speaking for loss of
conservatives also you know some
libertarians said that Robert
substituted one unconstitutional
expansion of government power for
another and said that Roberts gave this
vast new taxing power so are they were
they is that is that editorial wrong are
they overly negative about the decision
air punch line is right he did he did
substitute one unconstitutional version
for another but what he ended up doing
was somewhat clever deal is it cleverly
although I'm not I don't admire it is
that he substituted a much less
dangerous unconstitutional principle for
a much more dangerous one that's exactly
the reason why this was a pretty big
important victory what the justification
for the law was supposed to be was the
Commerce Clause that's that's how the
law is written as a regulation of
Commerce and if Congress
regulate you when you're not doing
anything that is a huge expansion and in
fact the theory under which that
expansion is justified is essentially
the Congress has the power to address
all national problems it's as though we
have a national problems clause in the
Constitution and if and that's what most
law professors actually believe and if
that were true that would be the end of
the enumerated power scheme what Chief
Justice Roberts substituted for that in
what he called a saving construction in
which he admitted was not the
appropriate reading not the best reading
of the text was a tax power but not the
tax power that law professors had been
advocating law professors said that oh
well you could just do this whole thing
under the tax but he's just called it a
tax it'd be the same but that's not what
he did he said well it's written like a
tags if you take the requirement out
first of all you got to take the
requirement out there was a requirement
that everybody buy insurance well you
got to take that out because that's
that's unconstitutional under the
Commerce Clause so you take the
requirement out what's your left is with
the penalty and the penalty he said is
so low that it could actually be a tax
and not a penalty so he really made a
distinction between a penalty and
attacks he said the mandate was not a
penalty because it was so low if it had
been higher it might have been a penalty
and it would been unconstitutional
because it would be coercive so what he
really said is that Congress can tax in
activity as long as those taxes allow
people to make a choice but if that
monetary exactions he said ever got so
punitive that it would be coercive in
that case it would be a penalty and it
would be unconstitutional he implied it
would be unconstitutional that wasn't
before him so they substituted a less
dangerous tax power for a far more
dangerous Commerce Clause power if the
Commerce Clause power had been upheld
not only with the enumerated power
scheme had gone away but Congress could
have punished this changed the law to
punish this or any future mandates by a
very extensive penalties like high fines
and even imprisonment one last way of
explaining the difference imagine that
all the drug laws were justified under
the tax power and not under the commerce
power all the drug laws we have or
Commerce Clause power but imagine they
were only justified under the tax power
under the principle that Chief Justice
robbers identify that would mean that
the only thing the government could do
to you for violating drug laws would be
to charge you a reasonable modest tax
they couldn't even charge you a punitive
tax and they certainly couldn't put you
in jail if we actually achieve that
reading of the Commerce of the of the
drug laws it wouldn't be a perfectly
libertarian solution but you'd have to
open up the jail's and let millions of
people out under that reading of the
Constitution the word unprecedented has
been used a lot I invented them with
that I invented it I hope you're getting
you know royalties every time it's used
but but it seems to me and I've argued
this that Roberts a pinion is quite
unprecedented because it's he's putting
forward an argument that we haven't
really seen before I mean is that
correct yeah it's absolutely correct he
appears to be the only person in the
United States and certainly the only
legal commentator who holds the view
that he announced last week and that is
this view that the Commerce Clause makes
the mandate unconstitutional because it
mandates an activity it converges it
compels commerce in order to regulate it
that's unconstitutional therefore we
have to adopt a saving construction to
eliminate the requirement and the
penalty can be justified as a tax which
can't be more than a reasonable amount
that is unique to him no one's ever
identified that to you before no one who
supported the mandate no academic who
supported the mandate has it held that
view no judge who's considered this case
has held that view no other justice
holds that view this view is unique to
Chief Justice Roberts and was unknown
until he announced it and that should
tell you something about whether it was
a legally compelled outcome because if
it was if this was the obvious best
legally compelled outcome someone would
have held it before and no one did so if
it's not a legally compelled outcome
what's what's the explanation well the
the it's circumstantial evidence that
this was a politically compelled outcome
and in fact I'm not exactly sure why
that would even be so controversial to
say since all the people on the left
from the president ought to the from the
President to the chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee on down to columnist
like Jeff Rosen we're urging justice
Chief Justice Roberts sometimes in
particular to save the legitimacy of the
court by not going along with a
five-to-four can
servet of liberal decision striking down
the president's signature legislation
well everything I just said in the
sentence our political considerations
none of which relates to the
Constitution or even two Supreme Court
doctrine about the Constitution it all
relates to political considerations and
if those were the considerations urged
upon him that persuaded him to cop out
in the way he did then that makes it a
political decision but I want to clarify
be clear about one thing it's not like
I'm saying that it was a political
decision in the sense of the five
justices who voted to uphold Obamacare
were acting politically what I'm saying
I think four justices were acting in
principle they have a principle view
that there's a national powers clause in
the Constitution that's their principal
view and then four justices were acting
in principle against that view one
justice the swing justice his view was
the one that was possibly motivated
politically let me read you a passage
from Roberts opinion he said it is not
our job to protect the people from the
consequences of their political choices
I mean that's you know what's what's
wrong with that that's sort of like the
classic argument for judicial restraint
you know we have a presidential election
coming up why not just take it to the to
the ballot box I mean that's exactly
wrong it is the courts job to protect
the people from the consequences of
their political choices when they
violate the Constitution of the United
States which is a higher law also
enacted by the people to [ __ ] to to
check Congress and the other branches of
government the Constitution is the law
that governs those who govern the people
and it was put in place by the people so
the people who are supposed to be bound
by that law which is the Congress and
the courts in the president they can't
change it to make it more suitable to
them it's the end it's the courts job to
follow the Constitution which is the
higher people's law and so it is very
much the job of the court to protect the
everyday transient will of the people
assuming even by the way that Obamacare
was part of the will of the people which
the only evidence for that is it got a
bare majority of demigod you got a bare
majority of Democrats he got the
requisite number of Democrats to vote
for it that's the only evidence that
it's quote the will to people and it is
the job of the court to protect the
people when they were acting in their
sovereign capacity
of attacking a constitution from that I
want to go back to the Commerce Clause
part of the case for a second so so the
Chief Justice accepts your arguments and
entirely that that this is an
unprecedented exercise of congressional
power under the Commerce Clause and then
four dissenting justices and let me
interrupt you it's unprecedented the
courts are empowered to enforce it and
the individual insurance mandate
violates it he said all three of those
things that was our whole case so we
have five justices who accept your
arguments entirely so is is that a
binding ruling is that is is that I've
seen legal commenters say well that's
you know that's just dicta that's that's
not something that binds future courts
or lower courts but what's what's your
view others it's a technic the dicta
holding distinction is a technical
distinction in law and there's i would
say for purposes of this interview two
different ways of looking at it sort of
the technical way and that is were there
five votes were there five justices in
support of them of the pinion of the
court which identify what the holding
was and it turns out that there were it
turns out that the liberal justices
signed on to part 3 of Justice Roberts
opinion in which he said that the
holding of this court is that the comp
that you cannot be compelled into
activity under the Commerce Clause and
so we're going to do the saving
construction and set instead it says the
court holds this and four liberal
justices signed on to that part of the
opinion so it has five justices that
makes it the holding of the court that's
one way of looking at it the other way
that's really in summary in that that's
the way that is pertinent for lower
courts in terms of future Supreme
Court's and the general public and the
public generally we nor we the other way
of looking at is pragmatically are there
five votes to uphold something if you
went to a district court judge judge in
the future what a district court judge
look up at the Supreme Court and say are
there five votes for drawing a line in
article and article one and saying
Congress can't go that far well clearly
there are so if you just look at it
doctrinally or if you look at it
pragmatically it's the holding of the
case one of the criticisms that I know
that you've received and the legal
challengers have received is that this
case that your arguments we're going to
be they're going to overturn the New
Deal they were going to get to bring a
mayor
go back to the horrors of the Gilded Age
and a return to Lochner and so forth but
in fact if you actually read your briefs
and your arguments they they were based
entirely on the idea of precedent and
that this you know that this was a case
to case of first impression and that the
Supreme Court had never allowed
something like this before so but so
having said that so if the arguments are
crafted to the to the specific facts of
the case and to the unprecedented will
mandate Obamacare so if the mandate
isn't upheld under other grounds are
there other practical benefits of aside
from the lower courts looking up at the
it's really funny David I mean for two
years I've been hearing if you know if
my if Barnett's view or are the
challengers view is except that it's
going to threat to the entire post New
Deal apparatus and it's got its a return
to the bad old days etc etc and I've
been denying this I've been saying that
it would apply that if we win it'll
apply to one law that ever been passed
it passed the Affordable Care Act the
individual mandate because it's the
first time Congress did this and it
won't it'll leave as you say we haven't
challenged any precedent it will leave
all precedents in place it will leave
all laws in place it will actually be a
very limited victory the day after the
opinion is issued I'm hearing liberal
commentators like Jeff stone former dean
of Chicago Law School saying you know
this is actually a very limited opinion
it only applies to mandates and they're
probably not going to do mandates again
anyway exactly what I've been saying all
along all right so in that sense it's
very limited however there's two ways of
looking at it first of all had we lost
it would not have been limited had we
lost then we would have had a national
problems clause in the Constitution and
Congress would have had the power that
all law professors wanted to have which
is the power to do anything it wants
with respect to the economy it clearly
they clearly were refuted I mean the
view that 99% of law professors hold
today could not command five votes at
the Supreme Court it got four votes at
the Supreme Court and it could not
command five that's huge that's huge but
even more so it basically says as I was
saying before the Commerce Clause has
limits the supreme court will enforce
those limits and here's a third
important thing the Necessary and Proper
Clause is cannot be used as an end run
around
those limits which by the way there was
much less case law on we had that was
the in some sets the doctrinally week as
part of our argument which we had some
case law but we didn't there was a
Supreme Court said very little about the
Necessary and Proper Clause we argued
that even though the Supreme Court is
deferential meant for your listeners the
necessary Proper Clause says Congress
shall have power to make all laws which
shall be necessary and proper for
carrying into execution the foregoing
powers the Supreme Court's been very
deferential about what's a necessary law
they basically defer to Congress the and
a lot of people have claimed that the
word proper doesn't do any independent
work our theory was based on the idea
that proper is separate from necessary
and this was however necessary this law
was to the Affordable Care Act it was an
improper means you know most law
professors most legal authorities
rejected that idea in fact there's very
little Authority one way or the other on
that we had some for example the Prince
case that said commandeering state
officials is improper but anyway this
case made fantastic law Chief Justice
Roberts said specifically that the
mandate was an improper means under the
Necessary and Proper Clause for
enforcing the Commerce executing the
Commerce clower so what our contention
on the Necessary and Proper Clause was
also there and in terms of what this
means for the future the future depends
on what future courts wanted future
justices want to do let's be realistic I
mean I've been realistic from day one
let's be realistic it all depends on
what future justices want to do number
one if future justices want to protect
the enumerated power scheme they won't
have a super bad precedent standing in
their way which they would have if we
have lost on the Commerce Clause and
number two they've got a tremendous
precedent for the idea that the
enumerated power scheme means something
and is legal and judicial e enforceable
the Necessary and Proper Clause is also
a constraint or it doesn't it's not a
blank check for government and that's a
huge accomplishment we've talked largely
about the Commerce Clause in this
interview so I wouldn't ask you about
the the spending power okay part of the
ruling which is they may be gotten it
has not gotten as much attention but
also was would that's also something you
consider a victory for your argument
it's huge victory and no one thought in
fact I didn't think that we had a chance
on that in fact i'm sure that paul
clemente who argued the case was
surprised that it would certainly even
granted on that
and and separate argument was devoted to
it and we actually won on that there has
never been a case before listen there's
never been case since the New Deal where
the court found any restriction on the
spending power and the power the spend
is actually not in the Constitution
there's a power to tax which presumably
includes the power to spend the money
that you that you get from the taxes and
there's been no judicial limitation on
that at all there was a case you know 20
years ago that said that you know if the
if the states were coerced if threatened
to have funds withheld that would coerce
them then that might be unconstitutional
but it wasn't in that case which
involved five percent of highway funding
and there no lower court had ever found
that line had been crossed well the
supreme court found that line had been
crossed 722 the vote was 722 that there
was a line and the spending power it got
crossed and then the remedy for that
which is again more than we expected
because we didn't expect to win on this
claim at all is that that that in the
with respect to these Medicaid funds the
Congress cannot withhold money for the
existing Medicare program in order to
get the states to agree to expansion of
that program a substantial really big
expansion of that program you know
agreeing to minor changes is one thing a
whole new thing is another thing and
they can't leverage the money they're
spending on existing programs to make
them do this or coerce them into doing
this other one this is a huge victory
also what's your sense of why there was
that the the sort of the liberal legal
establishment was just so overwhelmingly
opposed to these ideas and just seemed
to think that the idea that their
Commerce Clause post any sort of
limitations on congressional power was
just something that was just foolish
this is a really important question
since the New Deal liberal academia and
there is almost no diversity in liberal
academia that's a complete echo chamber
where they basically talk to each other
liberal academia has maintained that the
New Deal court's jurisprudence and the
Warren Court jurisprudence stands for
the proposition that Congress has a
national problems power they have the
power to solve any national problems
that especially national problems that
pertain to the economy which is when you
think about it everything that's their
view that's what they think the New Deal
stood for it's not what the New Deal
court ever said it's not even with the
Warren court ever said
although the Warren Court took it a
little farther than the New Deal court
and so but they've been teaching it this
week this way for 70 years that's why in
1995 when the Lopez case found a limit
they went berserk they went berserk and
you know now the Lopez is hello
precedent that they use to show oh they
believe in limits to look at Lopez but
at the time Lopez was conservative
judicial activism because it found any
limit at all because it violated their
fundamental belief that there were no
limits and so they dismiss Lopez as
being as being not serious and symbolic
and all Congress has to do is clean up
its findings and the court will break
then in the in the Morrison case the
Violence Against Women case in two
thousand when the court again held the
line and found something
unconstitutional then they got scared
and they thought oh wait a second maybe
the court serious and maybe we were
wrong and lower courts actually started
operating then and then in 2005 in the
rage case which is the case on behalf of
Angel rage and Diane Monson that I
represented them in the Supreme Court
all the way up to the Supreme Court when
they upheld the law in Raich and Justice
Scalia and Justice Kennedy crossed over
enjoying the liberals in upholding the
application of the controlled substance
act to what marijuana you grow in your
own backyard to consume yourself they
breed the sigh of relief they said we
were right all along this little blip of
new federalism is nothing maybe it's a
little symbolic thing but otherwise it's
nothing we're back to our default
position that Congress has unlimited
power when we made our argument now you
know seven years later there they were
already back in their original position
and we were arguing there's a limit and
they said that's crazy that's crazy that
violates everything we know now I've
mentioned the liberal echo chamber I
think that's in academia I mean on the
Georgetown faculty where I'm very
welcome and very well treated and I
really am happy you know we have about
110 faculty members of which three are
identifiably right of center and when
you and and and that makes us more
diverse than most elite law schools and
when you live in an echo chamber like
that it's okay to let somebody like me
in and but I can then be dismissed as an
outlier because I'm alone it's you know
so there you have the diversity of
hearing what I say but because it's 99
to 1 in a mean in academia generally
it's actually worse than that probably a
thousand
something like that but because it's
like that they can say well you guys you
may be it we hear you but we don't have
to take you seriously is that something
that's going to change I I don't know I
hope it will i have a new center at
georgetown called the georgetown center
for the Constitution that's gearing up
this fall one of its missions is to
bring fellows in who might go into
teaching and and other institutions are
doing similar things there's other
Institute's doing that it's going to be
a long process because in fact the bias
against libertarians and conservatives
in academia is overpowering in lockport
schools and other department law schools
in particular although i will say that
there is a greater bias towards
conservatives than there are tours
libertarians libertarians are considered
kind of you know safer or something a
little more interesting you know and
conservatives are more out there so
there's more bias against them than us
maybe I mentioned that a lot of people
will watch this video will be law
students read your work and and are
interested or even maybe high schoolers
interested in the Constitution in these
legal issues yes what would you for you
what would you say to them I mean what
would you say to you know is you know
it's it's if they're thinking about
maybe a career in law or just a lot of
work on constitutional issues I'd say
it's the fan it's the best career I can
possibly imagine and even being in the
minority it has its advantages big
advantages for one thing you're always
saying things different than everyone
else I think it would be a bigger
challenge to be in the 99 percent there
is a different version of the
ninety-nine percent were them in the 99
percent because you got to think of
something different to say when you're
basically saying the same thing as
everyone else I never have a problem
thinking of something different to say
so it's really interesting you're not
badly treated at all I'm treated very
respectfully whenever any out of the
blue when something actually
disrespectful happens it's so unusual
that I'm taking it back and I'm not even
sure how to respond to it if it happened
all the time I'd have defense mechanisms
all in place and and I think that's
partly if you treat other people
respectfully they treat you respectfully
back and the other part of it is is that
you know because there's this immense
discrimination we have to be better
really than our peers to get ahead and
so wherever we are whatever station we
are on the ladder of success you know we
are somewhat better than our immediate
peers because we had to be to get that
job and therefore we do pretty well it's
a fun life it's a great life
and I think the thing I sell
libertarians generally about this not
just academics or perspective academics
is that you know you can't make your
happiness contingent on getting a
libertarian Society the struggle for
liberty will never end because there's
always going to be status there's always
going to be people who prefer security
over Liberty because that's another part
of natural instincts that people have
and so the best that we can ever
accomplish is keeping Liberty alive and
you can keep Liberty alive just by being
a libertarian yourself and writing about
it and you know getting other people to
be even if the society you live in is
not you can at least keep the idea of
Liberty alive and possibly Liberty
itself you're also known as an exponent
of originalism yes original public
meaning original yes and so I wanted to
ask you about that but also that you you
have a section in your book restoring
lost Constitution originalism for now an
original asst right so I wonder if you
could just run down that argument well I
wasn't an original list for a long time
and so they all the early years I was
working on the Constitution and at some
point or another because I was talking
so much about the original meaning of
the Ninth Amendment and so much about
the original meaning of the Second
Amendment which is another amendment i
got into early on I started to have
cognitive dissonance why am I talking so
much about original meaning if I don't
think originalism is right and then just
by happenstance I mean this was just
totally weird I was teaching a seminar
on the Constitution and there was a
footnote to a book by Lysander Spooner
called the unconstitutionality of
slavery which was published originally
in 1845 long before the Civil War long
before the Thirteenth Amendment and I
looked at this footnote and I thought
what the heck could this be I know
Lysander Spooner but what seat of taco I
didn't know he did anything other than
no treason and so what's this about so I
had the library get me this and it turns
out it's a 280 page book about that was
published in 1845 about why the
Constitution doesn't sanction slavery
and the method that he used was the
method that has come to be known as
original public meaning originalism and
I had not seen that as a form of
originalism articulated before it turns
out in a parallel track others had been
moving in
direction unbeknownst to me Justice
Scalia for example had already moved to
original public meaning originalism from
original framers intent originalism
which is what i rejected and but and but
i got there through Lysander Spooner and
then I I work that up and eventually
found out other people were doing
similar things and then I kind of threw
my friend threw myself into that
position you bring up Lysander Spooner
was going to ask you then about because
you've been doing work in the last
couple years on the abolitionists and on
the Fourteenth Amendment right so did
did Spooner lead you to to study the
abolitionists more broadly absolutely I
didn't know anything about that all I
knew for many years was Spooner
Spooner's work and I was writing a book
on the Fourteenth Amendment which I'm no
longer writing because I got stuck on
the chapter on the abolitionists my
thesis was going to be the abolitionists
are going to be the key to the
Fourteenth Amendment and I got to the
chapter on the abolition as I ended up
taking two years just studying them and
what I what I discovered is something
that some historians know but no law
professors know and the historians don't
appreciate the legal significance they
just know these people existed there
really were two camps of abolitionists
there were the radical abolitionists
under the garrison ians and they were
anti-political they were called dis
unionists they actually wanted to
withdraw from the union and they were
anti political activity and most of them
became anarchists and because they had
the argument that they're arguing
against slavery is no person can rule
another and if they took that principle
and they applied it to government they
said well no person can rule another so
we're anarchist and and that's one camp
but there was this other camp that's not
known to be a camp of an ER of
abolitionists and one word that's used
to describe them is constitutional
abolitionists they believed in political
activity and they believed that the
Constitution actually was not
pro-slavery it was anti-slavery and they
pursued political action in order to end
slavery thief they founded initially the
Liberty Party which was a single-issue
anti-slavery party then they went on to
found the Free Soil party which was a
more moderate vision of this view and
eventually they formed the Republican
Party the constitutional plank of which
said that the Constitution does not
endorse slavery it just allows it in the
states that had it and
it was the constitutional commitments of
the Republicans that drove the South out
of the Union and ended slavery by means
of a war but let me just mention Spooner
here Spooner very interestingly was in
both camps he was an anti political guy
and but he kept his and so he wasn't a
fan of the liberty party in political
action and so he but he kept those views
quiet because he didn't want to alienate
his audience is he a lot of fans in that
clamp because he was a pro Constitution
guy so he was an in neither camp he was
neither he was against the garrison ians
anti constitutionalism he was against
the political activity of the
constitutionalist and as a result both
sides actually respected him quite a bit
especially the constitutional abolition
is he was kind of a hero an intellectual
hero to them and he was also a big
influence on Frederick Douglas Douglas
credits him for his own anti-slavery
reading of the Constitution Sounion in
fact he when he first heard the spooner
views he said you know that's just
making it up if that's just you know you
can't read your own views into the
Constitution and then shortly thereafter
he was persuaded by it and from then on
in he was one of the most articulate
advocates of the idea that this
constitution is not pro slavery and and
what what can what can the abolitionists
teach teach us today what's though you
know what I mean obviously you're very
interested in this you're doing a lot of
research on it I mean is there are there
lessons for the for the law today aside
from the original meaning or is that the
main no I think that they can teach a
lot of things but for purposes of this
interview the reason an interview I
think the abolitionists are the original
intellectual origins of modern
libertarianism I think modern
libertarianism can be traced back to the
abolitionists I mean and spooner is in
some respects the one of the principal
links there because he takes you all the
way up to the end of the 19th century
and the people he's hanging out with are
the precursors of the modern
libertarians and in the abolitionists
you see the modern libertarian movements
sort of schism although I think it's a
soft schism between the more radical
anarchistic type libertarians which are
the aptly arizonian types and the
and the constitutional libertarians who
believe both in political activity to
try to advance liberty and they believe
that the Constitution is a means for
doing so they believe both those things
I think if you look back at what was
accomplished then it was the
constitutional abolitionists that
actually ended slavery now you know I
think a critique can be made of what we
got in its place in terms of the
national government I understand that I
share that view in large measure but
they did get slavery done with and the
garrison ians but the Agera Sony ins
played important role in that too
because they made the moral case for it
in a way that appealed to a lot of other
people so look you had them both sort of
working in tandem with each other
critiquing each other but really on the
same page they were on the same page and
I don't think it's any coincidence that
the constitutional abolition is called
their part their anti-slavery party of
the liberty party and I just think
that's where we come from and we ought
to rediscover those roots we should be
proud of them I'm gonna read you a quote
this is justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
1905 a very famous descent he said the
Constitution does not enact mr. Herbert
Spencer's social statics now obviously
Spencer he's not so well known today and
to the extent that he to know any sort
of misunderstood but maybe we could
update that as you know the Constitution
does not enact you know the libertarian
principles of Reason magazine or the
libertarian principles of Randy Barnett
but you've addressed this question of
the Constitution's compatibility with
libertarianism or at the Cato Institute
a few years ago he gave a speech is the
Constitution libertarian right so what's
what's the answer well Holmes is wrong
about this as he was wrong about almost
everything he's one of my least favorite
judges I mean he was by the way you
Genesis he was a social Darwinist so
he's the end the opposite of a hero of
mine he's wrong to think it's it's
consistent with all political theories
and if it were true that it was
consistent all political theories you
wouldn't have to have a living version
of it that leaves out whole parts of it
why did they cut out the privileges
immunity clause why did they cut out the
Ninth Amendment why do they limit they
you know the Commerce Clause is making a
comeback but why was it why we're all
these parts gone because they got in the
way if they didn't get in the way you
could just use them but you got to get
rid of them because they're in the way
you can't have it both ways you can't
say the Constitution we have is
consistent with all political or all
legislative ends
all laws and then get rid of the ones
that get in the way so the Constitution
is compatible with libertarian
principles it's compatible with them and
it it actually is what has kept us a
freer Society I mean the other way of
looking at the Constitution is that the
mean one of the reasons why Spooner
eventually turned away from the
Constitution which he did later on was
he said look the Constitution either
gave us the kind of tyrannical
government we have or it was incapable
of preventing it from taking place and
you know I'm very sympathetic with that
view I was completely sympathetic with
that few years ago I'm less sympathetic
I'm still sympathetic but I don't buy it
entirely because I think one of the
reasons why we have as free as society
as we have is because of what's left of
the Constitution here's a way of
thinking of it the founders built
constitution that was so well engineered
that it built in so and it built in so
many redundant checks on power that even
if you get rid of this one and this one
and this one in this one just the ones
that are left are enough to keep us
relatively free it's as though you're on
a four-engine jet you've lost three of
your engines the last remaining engine
is still keeping you aloft because the
jet was well designed it was designed to
fly on one engine although that's not
optimal and that's where we are now
we're flying on one engine the what's
left of the Constitution it's still good
enough to keep us aloft but it would
sure be a lot better if we could get all
the anti engines fired up well that's a
great place to end thank you very much
Randy Barnett professor at Georgetown
Law Center one of the legal architects
of the challenge to Obamacare and the
author of many grade law review articles
and books your personal website Randy
Barnett com you also blog at the ball at
conspiracy everyone should check it out
thanks Damon thank you
you